James Cameron announced
four "Avatar" sequels,
and the last one doesn't
even come out until 2027.
That's so far away!
What if I don't live that long?
Look, I know I'm just a
prostitute your mom paid for,
but have ever tried Na'Vitamins?
They're specially formulated multivitamins
that contain over 38 key nutrients
designed to keep people
with an "Avatar" fan
body type just barely alive enough
to enjoy all the "Avatar" sequels.
And Na'Vitamins come in four strengths.
But will Na'Vitamins
keep me healthy enough
to do all my favorite activities?
Depends, like what?
Sit?
Sure.
Eat?
Uh- huh.
Sit?
Yup.
Cool, but what if I'm
already on my death bed?
Well if you've already been diagnosed
with a critical condition, you can upgrade
to the Unobtanium Life Drip.
It induces a medical coma
preserving just enough
brain activity to allow your
eyes to register movement.
And when you're all done, you're all done.
Wow, how do you know so much
about about these Na'Vitamins?
That's a prostitute's secret.
Na'Vitamins, finally a reason to live.